very happy to present today
i hope you had a great day to date um
the will be together for the next 30
minutes
um i will introduce you to mims
so a little bit of history on mims
um mimsy is a three years old company
software company based in montreal we
have to date 30 employees uh we raised
around uh three million dollars
uh in equity and and uh we signed over
the past 24 months
uh for four million dollar contracts
and the mission of memes is really to
develop what we call systems biology
software
uh to help life science companies
develop a more efficient
and personalized medicine and
agriculture and as you will see
all across the world from biopharma and
agriculture company
so what we're doing exactly for them uh
we are uh helping actually uh
the life science companies doing a very
critical transformation process of their
rmd
the the biopharma and agriculture
company
are uh are moving to identify their next
blockbuster drug
seed and breeds from a
molecular biology driven rnd
into systems biology machine learning
and computer
driver driving a
motor to to do their r d and this
involves actually
more and more modeling biological
systems so this modeling involved the
integration of different layers of
information
you have here multi-ohmic data so
genomic epigenomic transcriptomic
proteomic
metabolomic and so on information on the
phenotype
of the system whether the system is a
human so a patient for example a cow
or a plant and also integration
of the relationship with this system
with its environment
and this allows the generation of
a graph that represents uh the patient
and its interaction with the
with the with this environment this
involves also integration of a lot of
knowledge
uh coming from the public space and
mostly from the literature
now in this transformation process even
biggest organizations
are facing five major challenges the
first one being that
they have difficulties to build and
maintain an interdisciplinary team with
expertise in bioinformatics systems
biology
and machine learning that are required
to do this modeling
you guys and mila have a lot of
experience as a mathematician usually to
to discuss
with a lot of people and i'm pretty sure
that you have the experience of talking
to biologists and
witness the fact that really it's not
easy
to under understand each other so that's
what these companies and these
organizations are facing right now
the second challenge is really the fact
that to be able to do this modeling
uh the organization need to capture
maintain huge knowledge base that are
integrating
um knowledge coming from the public
space and this knowledge
is for off of it into unstructured
formats so
articles and text and for the second
half
it is structured but it's structured in
databases and in hundreds of databases
that are dispersed worldwide
so these organizations have problems to
aggregate this data
and also to maintain it and to update it
regularly
the life science industry is also
characterized by very heavy
and sensitive data so they are facing
computing challenges
and they're also facing security
challenges uh
for very sensitive data particularly
medical records of patients
and the last but not the least uh in
when you talk about
transformation process you talk about
adoption
problems and uh eighty percent of
um of the employees of this organization
that are involved in r
d are life scientists they are not
computer scientists and they don't have
expertise in coding
so you need this new approach to be
adopted by
these population of scientists
so admits we help them resolve these
five challenges with our platform
by providing them with ready-to-use
solutions
for biological systems modeling
integrating systems biology
bioinformatics and machine learning
these solutions are used in the
biopharma industry as you'll see in the
next slide
for population stratification target and
biomarker discovery for example
the platform is also providing them with
a comprehensive and up-to-date knowledge
base
that is built from structured and
unstructured sources
uh for the unstructured sources we use
nlp
otherwise we capture and integrate and
curate automatically and manually
um different databases that we integrate
into a massive ontology
the last the the third thing that this
platform is
bringing is is a cloud computing
infrastructure
that could be deployed retracted that
allows the data to be geo-localized
and also allows federated learning to
occur so that the data are now move
around and
and there are some learning that can be
done at every site
and the last uh the the the human
machine interaction
uh that simplifies very complex
process particularly the systems biology
one
uh and allow life scientists to really
dig into their results and understand
what is the root of uh of
uh the analysis this is done
um particularly in the machine learning
process
and all that is possible because
our software is built around a kind of
ar
that is a symbolic ai that we call
goal-oriented
massive multi-agent systems that are
used for reinforcement learning for
example but
that are operated here as an
organizational
uh center and core uh
of the software so our platform to date
allow biopharma and agriculture company
uh to have access to different solutions
for
uh target discovery uh so the first one
target discovery so we're bringing
patient stratification very early into
the process of target discovery
allowing biopharma really to identify
the heterogeneity
between patient population uh
in their target discovery process so
that they
are um they these helps them a lot to
have like
a more uh to prioritize target
that will be more efficient and
consequently have
lead that will be more efficient for a
subgroup of population
and in advance to know in which portion
of the population having a certain
disease
this lead will function on and on
another site where we have a lot of
traction in the biopharma industry is
really
before clinical trials uh right now
where we help
cooperation that have uh assets for
different
indication uh to prioritize uh
in which uh to prioritize the indication
they should pursue with their what their
clinical trial
in the agriculture space the equivalent
of
these these solutions or really into
precision breeding
and precision farming and i will show
you examples
of these different solutions
so uh how come we ended up with this
solution
actually means is really the results of
the integration of
uh the the the expertise of the three
co-founders um i myself a former canada
research chair in systems biology
i worked for eight years at mcgill and
for
13 years at ucam
[Music]
i've been actually blessed to come in
montreal from south of france
the year where the first human genome
got sequenced to do my postdoc
and totally fell in love with this uh
this uh systems biology that was just uh
um that was just like uh
coming uh with what we call at first
functional genomics and have as mentor
mark vidal from harvard that really
helped me into
this path um eight years ago i met
abdullah and michael actually
independently uh michael
uh is an ai specialist especially
his speciality is really in autonomous
systems
and goal-oriented massive multi-agent
systems he implemented these systems in
various robotics
projects uh in uh in
the aerospace and defense uh
in europe and also incorporated this
solution
in
when he arrived in montreal uh 15 years
or 13 years ago abdullah banier dialogue
was actually my
collaborator when i was a university
professor uh he's a bioinformatician
he received in 2018 the next einstein
pillow price
fellow prize for his career at the
interface of bioinformatics and machine
learning
and is extremely active in both
biopharma and also agriculture field
the technology of mems and our platform
is based on more than 30 peer-reviewed
publication
on the different areas that are required
to develop this kind of technology so
bioinformatics
uh systems biology and multi-homic data
integration machine learning for target
drug and biomarker discovery
ontologies cognitive informatics natural
language processing
and the goal-oriented massive
multi-agent systems
so how does this work and what are we
doing so this is example of
what we're doing for population
stratification uh
target and biomarker discovery basically
the pipeline
goes as as this so we plug we build api
to plug our platform through the source
of the data for clients
this data could be raw sequencing
mass spectrometry text
uh data uh they could go in a structure
pipeline where they go through
bioinformatic pipeline
quality controlled by informatica
pipeline uh could go also through an lp
uh pipeline to extract and structure
knowledge
then after it goes into our systems
biology engine
this systems biology engine actually uh
allows
these pieces of data to be integrated
one to another and also with our
knowledge base
means knowledge base uh that is actually
built uh from different components i'll
go back on that slider just
move right now on the knowledge base so
the knowledge base is basically uh a
knowledge that is
my gigantic ontology where
the knowledge is organized in different
layers
that are the different layers that are
representative of biological systems
in these layers we integrate different
uh
databases we have to date 41 databases
that are integrated into memes ontology
as well as knowledge graph from uh
[Music]
directly from the literature that is
built using nlp and ontologies
and also we integrate data from patients
that we collect
from public sources
so once this integration is done this
integration actually is done
to generate two kind of graph what we
call a genetic interaction graph
which will capture for a given system a
tumor for example or
immune system uh the the functional
relationship between genes and this is
inferred through
supervised machine learning techniques
and we're also inferring a systemic
graph that is capturing the
multi-discipline
the multicellular aspect of the system
and also
its inter interaction with its
environment
um and in there you have also the
phenotypical
data so the clinical data are integrated
in there these two graphs are
interconnected
they constitute what we call the id
graph and after that we use
uh graph embedding and graph
classification to so we generate one id
graph per patient and and after we use
graph embedding and graph classification
techniques
uh that could be either unsupervised or
supervised
to classify patients based on their
graph
or sub parts of these graphs
and after that we use pattern capture to
identify
different kind of things whether we're
looking for targets or
or biomarkers there are different ways
where after
after manipulating these graphs so
just a focus on our knowledge base
because this is
kind of interesting assets that uh
biopharma really
appreciates and and allow them to
actually enrich a lot
their proprietary data so we have a
process where we
implement actually uh our knowledge base
we give access to our
knowledge base to clinicians and this
will start actually
from march where clinicians will be able
to serve this graph
and will help us to give feedback on it
and some kind of validation
and this knowledge bases then after uh
nurture
uh our solutions for population
stratification
uh that are used by bioforma for target
and biomarker discovery
we have the different case studies that
showed that
our approach is very good to identify
targets though we have shown with a
success rate of 45 percent in validation
lab that our gi graph and id graph the
first neighbors
of a target of disease genes here
genetic
disease genes associated to genetic
diseases
or potent therapeutic targets and we
have been able to validate that for in
the form of duchenne muscular dystrophy
and
a rare mental retardation
disease we have also shown that
doing this target discovery on a graph
on stratified population here in
oncology
by comparing a graph for example here on
tnbc and luminal a
increased by 8 to 10 times our ability
the performance of
identifying therapeutic targets here
for controlling metabolic reprogramming
at the end bc
so to date this technology is
is used uh
on different projects and i'll just make
a very
brief overview of uh what we're doing uh
currently so
our technology is used uh for
two clinical trial in oncology in
collaboration with mark basic at the joy
of general hospital this is a project
that is funded by cqdm
and in collaboration with executives as
well
this project aims to identify biomarkers
to identify subgroup of tnbc patients
that are chemo resistant
and that are bad or good
responders to capacitabin which is a
second chemotherapy that is to date
given to
all patients and the second project was
dr mitrakos at the muhc
funded by midtech where the goal here is
to identify biomarkers
for good responders to angiogenic
treatment
on patients with colon cancer and liver
metastasis
for this project we're collecting
clinical data
from tumor we're collecting genomic
transcriptomic microrna data
and from exosome purified from blood uh
we get
microrna and protonic data and the goal
here is to primarily
try to find a biomarker circulating
biomarkers so biomarker from blood
and if not possible
biomarkers from a tumor resected
from patients we have
also a progen a project with a big
pharma
i cannot uh the name of this form is
still confidential so i will not be able
to disclose it but
uh the project is a project of target
discovery for
autoimmune disease uh in this project
we're collecting clinical data
genomic epigenomic transcriptomic
proteomic metabolomic
flow cytometry data uh from uh
around 2000 patients um
from blood uh here uh the the
the objective here is really to model
the immune system of this patient
to identify subgroup of patients with
the different autoimmune diseases
and after that to identify new targets
in
every sub-populations
in the agriculture side we had like a
project with navajo which is
a high-tech uh cannabis company
uh based in the north shore of quebec
um this company actually has a vision
really to
go into multiomic which is not
that frequent for cannabis company so it
was
really good to be involved in this
project so in this project we're
collecting
uh genomic transcriptomic metabolomic
data
from plants in the
growth facility and as well as data
from sensors the goal here was really to
model the plant
to help them to improve their production
so optimization of plant production
and also to optimize the breed so we are
really here
in precision breeding and precision
farming for these clients
another project in in in the farming
space
uh so that was actually one of our first
project uh we are actually starting a
second project with the same
uh group of people was a project that is
funded by
genome canada and recently got funded
refunded actually by krubik in this
project
uh in collaboration with ucam university
levan mcgill
and vallecta who which is the
the organization setting the price of
milk and doing a lot of
farming advisory um for farmers in
quebec
uh we are collecting from um
1.6 million cows genomic
earth production food and climate data
the goal here is really to optimize
animal health
to optimize farm production and
profitability
in the second project we're actually
using
techniques to capture anomalies in
dynamic data
in order to identify and
characterize the resilience of the cows
so that's a new project but in the first
project that we carried out
uh with them uh we've got
uh publication and we are actually
functioning in this project
a lot of uh the research associated to
the project
is done actually in the lab of abdullah
our cso
and where industrializat putting all
that in industrialization that means
and incorporating it uh into the
platform
as we as we talk so for this project
we we generated a knowledge graph
that contain elements on pedigrees
production genetic
genetic health herd nutrition and
environment
we used lstm deep learning
model to be able to from input
production input that was dynamic
patterns to output uh the production for
the year
the next year and actually being able to
interfere
with a 90.6 percent accuracy whether
a cow will be productive next year here
is the
is the curve actually it's a little bit
edgy here but it should be
like rounder it's just that we don't
have a lot of point in this part here
but
this shows actually uh that models are
becoming extremely efficient from 100
000 cows so basically we didn't need
like the 1.6 million cows to be able to
to a very efficient model and this model
is actually
performing a lot the arima model that is
a model that is currently used
um in uh in this industry right now
so that's that's a summary of what we're
doing
uh i have no visibility or who is on
board so i just go on my
next slide just to thank people at memes
and also to tell you that uh memes is
is growing fast we're looking for a lot
of people right now we are growing at
the pace of
two a new employee per month so please
uh if you're interested to hear more and
you're passionate about
machine learning and ai and really
interested
and and already have experience in life
science particularly just do not
hesitate and contact me at sarah
memes.ai or directly going to our
website
and i'll stop the presentation so that
maybe i can see
somebody and take any question
you might have so thanks a lot for your
attention
do not hesitate to contact us please
apply
for internship or whatever
we're looking actively looking for
people so
and we have a very great team very happy
to introduce the team to you as well
so thanks for the invitation and
i think i stop here if you don't have
any
other questions thank you
bye